what's up gamers you like video games
what but you never play we're here to
review e3
2019 xbox playstation i didn't look at
playstation did they have theirs yet
sony isn't attending e3 2019 oh
okay well that saves me some time juice
let's start off with bethesda
with a game there is no game without the
players
really it all comes down to you you keep
us in check
you keep us in check is basically
codeful yeah we made some
games and through all of it
you're always there with us and you are
definitely not afraid to tell us how you
feel
[Music]
what did fallout 76 getting rating again
2.7
oh my god bruh your feedback sometimes
challenges us
but it forces us to be always
challenging ourselves
you empathize with us this whole
conference to me just sounded like
we're we're still friends right sorry
about that really bad game with it but
we're still cool right like we're our
friends here our fifth annual e3
showcase
get off the stage we won todd
yeah it's todd howard
great to see everybody did you guys know
todd howard was in the chess club
who's laughing now
yes i was in the chess club we have had
an incredibly exciting year at bethesda
game studios
given some of that excitement impressed
you're still here
i love him all the bad
games are totally fine as long as tart
howard makes a joke about it see that's
the face you make when you have a
game rated 2.7 actually over the last
year
we've had over 60 million players in our
games
wow most ever they have over 60 million
play
how can we say something good about the
situation oh god anything oh we have too
many players
but did they have fun we have a lot of
players
there's corporate buzzwords i mean like
everything is great
everything is good we have a lot of
players what's that
only 41 of them like the game but why
were so many of them
a type of game we'd never done before
had a lot of difficulties at launch we
had a lot of difficulties at lunch
oh really you don't see can we edit out
the oh
oh my god oh oh oh i guess we can't edit
out this means because
it happens that is amazing oh my god
what just happened
what's going on here
a lot of well-deserved criticism
yeah your game man not good
team kept working on it and you kept
playing it
well maybe if you stopped releasing
unfinished games todd
but the development team were working on
it and they were
they should have just done it from the
beginning todd you're making me angry
todd
and then in comes these two guys i don't
know they just said a couple things
and that one guy had an awkward laugh
before
[Applause]
it's kind of cute
but speaking of cute thank you arigato
such
[Music]
i ask myself this question every time i
go to the office
just kidding just kidding justin
we are very excited let's take a look
meet annette thank you bye-bye
yeah i don't care about the game
and then for some reason the yang
started just amping up
i don't know who this guy is i don't
know why people are so excited
wow thank you
thanks thank you everyone wow
thank you yeah
[Applause]
and gaming the elder scrolls online
has dragons dragons
of the world of tamriel what happens
next
check out elsewhere the latest chapter
new players
yeah oh i can play necromancer
everyone say yeah everyone's saying they
had a paid audience they're clearly just
trolling
like before then keep an eye out for a
dungeon dlc adventure called scale
breaker which you'll see in
august
nobody bethesda e3 crowd yeah
[Applause]
some more awkward laughs anyone you
would like some okay here we go
you think i'm going to talk about the
games really no one cares
this is like talking about commercials
then they brought out the
i think the most swedish person they
could find
hello everyone after liberating america
from the nazis come in wolfenstein ii
the new colossus
hello everyone
we don't all talk like that all right
after killing all the nazis come
[Music]
in this video game it
this year we take you back to europe
with two
new wolfenstein games we take you back
to your
why is it funny it's not even funny even
more evil nazis to kill
wow
[Laughter]
oh god that was beautiful out of
thousands of people in the audience
they're like
okay that girl show her in the center
now never seen someone so enthusiastic
you know that's a girlfriend being
dragged into this just kidding all these
people
they don't have girlfriends because
they're gamers brofist if you're a gamer
too
and then finally we get to the doom
stuff that's the good stuff that's what
i
that's the game this whole time i'll be
like come on dude
innovation and creativity is in our dna
and a very large neck
jesus christ look at that thing my god
sorry and all of these advances were
that's a big neck come on all right
moving on we got ea e8 was so goddamn
painful to watch
it's four hours goodness give me give me
the hog vince let's get it going
yeah yeah we're talking about star wars
they're making a star wars game it's
star wars
it's a star wars game you act like it's
so nonchalant you're making this
game please keep it going they're making
a star wars game
wow that's so cool so they added greg
greg i know his name is greg instead of
that guy from last year i guess they
listened to feedback so you know i gotta
appreciate that ea
the guy from last year i mean come on
why didn't you rehire him i don't
understand
bring back e3 2018 guy
come on it's like they picked up on all
the cringe right they're like
all right how can we reduce the cringe
please i don't like it so
everybody's anxious to see what this 15
minutes is going to be listen
we have more maps so let's deliver a
brand new one to you
this is also goddamn without the cringe
it's just boring
i don't care the fight no ea you were
supposed to deliver
i'm so disappointed we can't wait to let
you play it
yeah that's the true excitement
yeah come on this is why you need to
hire the ubisoft people
[Applause]
yeah just want to see
if skate 4 is happening or not i get it
i'm the same
where is skate 4 what is up madden
fans i am your host adam rank
nobody one person
of course we're going to come to ea play
we've got a booth out there look at the
guy in the background
you know it doesn't matter what we think
it only matters what the players think
they're the ones playing the game so if
they love it great
and if they don't they'll tell us the
feedback and we'll do our best to
address it well thank you ben
get back to work oh oh oh
man how are you doing i threatened to
hug i want everybody right now this is
serious
okay this is serious get your hands
together because joining us here on the
stage here in just a moment
is one of the best wide receivers on the
planet
from the pittsburgh steelers from the
university of southern california
a hardcore madden fan ladies and
gentlemen
all the way in the back give it up for
juju
smith juju
oh juju of course
wow that's so sick i brought a couple of
codes here for juju we're gonna give
juju some codes as well uh we're also
going to be sharing our social channels
check that out juju smith schuster there
he goes
handing out those codes i don't know
that you're going to get those back
well that's kind of the point of giving
them out sorry okay
okay we're gonna kick to somebody else
for this announcement
okay so here's joey graceffa hello there
everyone
i'm jorge sofa and if you didn't know
producer and content creator
youtuber i love this they learned from
last year we need a youtuber for this
make them pre-recorded god damn it thank
you
what up guys thank you for having me ea
need for speed um payback
uh if you guys didn't know need for
speed payback
i'm um
yes great game and i'm so excited to
announce this upcoming partnership with
one of my favorite games
so this summer the sims is actually
partnering with
the um this is why i'm proud to be a
gamer
this is to me what gaming is all about
where's his [ __ ] gaming channel did
this become his
gaming channel bring back shirtless joey
graceffa gaming
please welcome back everyone to another
episode
of sim sam anya so in the
then we have xbox xbox
it's such a weird culture on xbox i
really don't get it like these people in
the crowd
go in xbox
i'm a gamer gamer for life
overall it was a pretty boring
conference there's not much to say about
it
i didn't really was that interested
about anything oh my god it's kiona
reeves
yaya
oh my god he's there
please i
[Applause]
i love him so much
oh my god the screams please
jesus stop
oh my god that was actually me
i was there that would actually be me if
i meet kiana
but the best part of course okay let me
tell you
where's this the feeling of of being
there
of walking the streets of the future is
really going to be breathtaking
you're breathtaking you're all
breathtaking did he just say i'm
breathtaking
then mad booty came out please welcome
there's nothing really to say about it
but his name is matt booty so i thought
it was worth it
head of xbox game studios matt booty
his name is booty september 10th
oh wow gears of war five that's so
awesome
oh whoa why even bother then came in
hello i'm french and i don't know what
to do with my hands hello everyone
yes we've got your back
new content free updates and many
surprises
inspired by our community and that was
e3 pretty much
in a nutshell 2019 it's pretty
disappointing i feel like they've
learned
each each year they're learning how to
avoid the cringe
what started off as something so
beautiful it's now just become a stale
corporate
marketing event i've seen the chat boys
this might be the last one
my name is pewdiepie and brofist
what you never played super simulator
you know it's fun right i'm not supposed
to give my opinion
but give it a try and then you can tell
me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay i'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price